I wonder which charity is gonna pick in
this particular batch because kinetic
lash I believe using IV right yes yeah
it's pretty much just just all IV all
the time okay that's one of the
interesting things about how many IVs
there are in America is surprisingly
they all play just differently enough
that um you know sure sure you can you
can put regular IV match up knowledge
versus each person because that's just
kind of the bare minimum
yeah but they played just differently
enough that you can you really have to
start playing to the player to a point
sure kinetic lash in particular one of
your strongest suits is I feel like he
understands the ring out game with IV
better than most of it right right his
game is a little bit different but his
ability to put you into hangout
situations is I I feel like phenomenal
well this match is about to go underway
let's see who is gonna move on this is
winter side action what are these two
players will be in a nice position here
to move onwards alright starting it off
here and it's gonna be Sophie yeah I
mean you know he's got so many strong
results with Sophie at this point you
know I got second to only same and
kumite right there's gonna be big - he
gets the shoulder the follow up let's
see what kind of wake up and he is
pushing imports the edge of the ring is
that happening for no I think it's a
little bit too far not catching the role
he just delayed he's able to get this
done right there knee but I mean kinetic
is fighting on the glass plate so that's
why you see him backing up he's trying
to put himself in an advantageous
position where he could possibly
reversal right now there's been nine
beers that's gonna get it oh my gosh see
he's the knowledge of making someone
ring themselves out is insane okay
there's the Jian
what for they're just short of it oh
this is being it on that so look at that
all that damage already early odd gets a
follow-up here
oh yeah jumping to your choice
controller right there but okay simplify
I find it back a lot of clothes so it's
gonna be able to block this just fine
and there's no punish not a full task
view but you know okay got the launch
wasn't ready for it though I mean I
don't know many people who'd be ready
for that on the fly get to follow up
here with the Gumbel let's see what he
does gets the pressure there ya know
just frame so it's not Plus and he
should I believe if that III funeral
reason why would yes
event that's smart I mean you got to be
able to use it you use it or lose it
right that's the thing is especially in
a situation where you could close out
the round yeah well I definitely don't
yeah I cannot afford to lose right
Sophie said it for me
all right side up on rounds here lotta
meter coming in for academic class let's
see does he break the secondary
and you gotta remember this is a big
round once a player gets to their
potential final round they gain a full
stock of meter so that's something that
players have to be aware about a really
good job the kinetic lash I finally get
the throw wait for that round it's got a
good amount of meter to work with to
assure kinetic classic got in his barn
but he didn't use his whole chart
offensively if you so choose or if you
feel Freddie you know all you try to
keep him with the step able to get that
launch the follow up here
oh he got up again Zephyr kind step game
phonetic you know push him back nice
follow up here and just that pressure
right now and then clash fighting back
that's a combo oh yeah and it's a so
much damage they ran out of scaling they
ran out there we go Oh that'll aid on
the wake up by rolling wake up with a c
e gonna finish it off hurricanes FBI
yeah good read their it good reactions
actually able to pull it out and zip up
now can edit class she's gonna have to
rethink some of his approach there
yeah he was definitely catching him with
a lot of steps and then like repo right
like SEP I was he wouldn't even stop
wait kinetic wouldn't press button get
caught out and that that was a lot of
cyber cons damage obviously he hit him
with a couple of two things like that
but his ability to get into this
discharge sidestepping to create more
opportunities for himself you seen it
time and again at least at this matchup
already getting keep hopes getting side
throws series on the tech roll kinetics
up is game plan in command right back at
you separate eyes playing a bit
differently way more aggressive right
now anything stepping in the following
you said it right before we got in here
his presence of vibe for the ring out
game look at that kinetic clack to route
straight now he shot no it's like that
fell into the trap he fell into it cuz
then we were just talking about Shepherd
I was getting inside he was going is
taking a beating he was actually just
getting off yeah show me a power now bad
position have to be careful here does
not want to get ringing up again taking
a lot of damage right there though okay
no plus brings on that but the soul
church guts come out you know he's not
the legitimate scare attacking I guess
he was looking for the lower jaw wide if
buddy was going through maybe
Tuukka baby right there yeah I feel like
that's what he I mean yeah I feel like
that's what he was probably scouting but
still gets the big hit their ban that
was huge one to one and we're already
back in a cage and everything you think
this is the right thing that he wants a
fella it's already good proven that
there was so many ring ups at last match
well I mean you know there would be
other stages where ring outs would be
entirely more prevalent to be quite
honest with you and a lot easier for Ivy
to get here yeah maybe me sometimes you
want to put it into the luck of the draw
right continue the pressure catalyst but
it was just a bit off axis were they
unable to continue and get shoulder tax
several times you hate to see that kind
of scramble where you don't think just
fall apart
why did you see the ring do that
oh nice delay on that little charge on
the case he's been talking quite a few
of those first and I get to see damage
off this as well Wow kinetic clash one
round away from moving on to the winners
side step aside now having pretty much
full meters there it is yeah I can't
blame something cry for not being ready
for that because that was actually the
first time you went for it but that was
are you safe
yeah that was sick he was able to be
there get some damage out of it and look
at this putting the pressure on but
kinetic lash push it back yeah he's not
gonna take that bandage right now is
that guy still and there's continued
he's trying to goad him into the reverse
ring out situation so well for it he's
got the life leave will he keep pressing
oh man he is sneaky he's doing something
a series is he's looking at it yeah that
requires being incredibly patient on
that I think he's recognized that he's
trying to be as aggressive as possible
while also making kinetic think that
he's goading him doing a great job of
that and that caught in the round in my
opinion he's got two bars up right now
gotta throw at the edge of the Ring oh
that would have been big too if he
landed that clean
gi's miss but no punish on that they're
stepping trying to get each other away
from their own for situations there's
the lethal it's yeah I was gonna say
it's a weird situation on that one I'm
not too sure yeah unable to get anything
media out of it but let's see what he
does here he does have the sole charge
at the ready oh gee hi excellent that
was porch it's gonna get the fee here
yeah just wants to get the kill push it
to a final round here and this is where
it's gonna count this is the final round
and he's gonna have the same amount of
meter that kinetic is going into it so
there was such a strong Lisa far to
finish it out this is it one twice final
game final round it's a bit back and
forth entreaties to it this time getting
a throw let's see if he's gonna continue
that aggression that we saw in Prior
rounds any throw that hasn't been
touched by kinetic has pretty much not
been tacked I don't know that's the
danger zone right now so you got to be
careful you don't want it duck or you
don't want to throw out to throw
errantly and they just get wrung out for
that gonna give me many things but okay
everybody's favorite throw now what's he
gonna do here has a good chance
oh but you could never count open-ended
clash Oh getting it with the 9b he's
done that so twice in the matchup both
in crucial rounds I think it was three
times yeah yeah it's like we saw it
happen to slow motion well it was
interesting because it was specifically
trying to make a kinetic think that that
was the proper way to go right and so he
actually avoided the first hit of it but
then walked into the second
unfortunately dr. Eve the ground bounce
and that paved the way jeez what a set I
mean back and forth you couldn't have
gone any closer than that but
unfortunately for Zephyr guy he's now
gonna go into the loser bracket where
he's going to have quite the challenge
ahead of